[Music]  widely known that professional  quarterback Tim Tebow has claimed to be  a virgin yeah kind of a virgin well a  website called ashleymadison.com  is calling that into question this is  true they've offered 1 million dollars  to anyone who can prove they've had sex  with Tim Tebow here's the article right  here they are really offering up yeah I  can't believe it it's amazing if you can  prove that you've slept with Tim Tebow  you will get 1 million bucks  but if you're thinking right now coming  forward don't bother  someone's already collected the money we  don't know who it is we're not sure  [Music]  none of our business you know can  another identity it's not important  moving on you can say no if something's  too - meeting now are you telling yeah  oh he will  we won't listen to him but he can say no  earlier today today I love that that's  what he would do with them very subtle  very peaceful put half of it in his a  wallet can ruin the lines of this yeah  yeah